las declaraciones del presidente
las que anuncia que está esperada contra
ofensiva de la que tanto se ha hablado
en las últimas semanas tendrá que
esperar unos días o semanas más llegan
el marco de una entrevista dada a medios
que hacen parte de eurovisión que en
este momento se realiza en Liverpool
esto tendría que haberse realizado en
Ucrania que fue el ganador de la versión
anterior pero como consecuencia de la
guerra y esta invasión a gran escala
tuvo que realizarse en otro país en esta
vez resulta que es en el Reino Unido el
presidente y decía que esas brigadas que
han sido entrenadas en su mayoría por la
otan en los últimos meses y semanas ya
están listas que los hombres están
preparados pero que faltaban otras cosas
y que si se empezara esta batalla en
este momento Se podrían perder muchos
hombres y que esto era realmente
inaceptable él realmente no mencionó que
era exactamente lo que faltaba si decía
que algunas armas están por llegar días
atrás Estados Unidos aprobó un nuevo
paquete de ayudas a Ucrania que estará
destinado especialmente a fortalecer ese
sistema de defensa aéreo se puede se
piensa que es por allí pero también se
piensa que está relacionado con los
tanques Patriots 1 y 2 Todavía faltan
algunos por llegar y de llegar
exactamente a esas posiciones donde se
realizaría esa contraofensiva aunque
como se ha hablado en el pasado
realmente nadie sabe por dónde comenzará
y a qué nivel comenzará aunque muchos
hacen apuestas y empiezan a pensar que
es por esa región de saporilla que
comunica con la Península de crimea uno
de los grandes objetivos para recuperar
de las fuerzas ucranianas él también
dijo que ningún país podía presionar a
Ucrania para entregar territorio del que
y porque había que dárselo a Vladimir
Putin cuando se le preguntó sobre unas
posibles negociaciones y también habló
de la posibilidad de un cambio de
gobierno en Estados Unidos con las
elecciones del próximo año y él dijo que
esperaba que Ucrania hubiera ganado para
entonces